Chúng ta sẽ hả nổi một công an tổ chức lệ sốt quan đổi cứu nạn cứu hộ bộ công an lên đường từ ghét dân vô tại VN suy là
thường tưởng lế văn tướng, quý vinh chú văn gặp, thử chưởng bộ công an xu chỉ bội lệ,
không dự có bà, estelah, leo văn, kí ra ra suor s, đại biệt lâm thời đại xíu quan VN suy là tại VN.
Rồi nguồn thác của một công an của một mốt đồng chi, đây là những trên cí xí quan tình về nực đào thảo trên môn cao về tiêm cứu nạn cứu hộ trong một chường sắp lộ công trình.
Ê tế khẩn cấp, thông tì lệ lạc hầu cân ký thuật và chỉ quy hình chường.
Lực lượng đã chuẩn bị đầy đủ các phương tiệt chẳng tiếp bị truyền dục và tự ý tế thế bị giò tìm biểu nạn cứu hộ và hầu cân cẩn thiết
nhằm bảo đảm khả năng trình khả dân vụ nè khi đến hình chở.
Thử chưởng lế văn tướng khẳng đình, viên cử lực lực thăm ra cứu hộ cứu lạc tại VN suy là
Thế hợp tình thình đoàn kế cuúc tế, trách nhiệm dân đạo cuối Việt Nam, đông thời khẳng bị phái trò cuối Việt Nam là thành viên tích cửa có chính nghiệp trong cuộc đường cuối tế.
Bộ trử chưởng nạn cứu hộ cho trường, nhiều cầu, đoàn c控 tác danh trong uống đỉnh lực lực lượng khi đến tiện bàn.
Chủ đoàn phối hợp với lực lượng chiếm đăng nước sở tài, chiến khai dừng vụ theo đúng phần án, duy trí trẻ độ thống tim bảo cáo thùng xuất và tụt nối bảo đảm án toàn cho cắn buộ chiến sĩ trong xuất qua chiến thực hiện dừng vụ.